all right let's go on to the next
segment which is going to anger many
people in my audience i got a ton of so
let me back up last week we looked at
this interview
that jordan peterson did with joe rogan
and uh the interview was just word salad
after word salad of meaningless stuff
and predictably i got a lot of emails
from people saying david
you might not have understood what
jordan peterson was saying but it made a
lot of sense in particular his rant
about the bible and um unfortunately
you're wrong what jordan peterson said
about about the bible did not make a lot
of sense and so we're going to go
through now we did an overview of the
interview last week now we're going to
focus in specifically on jordan
peterson's rant about the bible which
makes no sense and there's a really good
there there's this uh subreddit called
ask a historian some people would say
ask an historian that's a grammatical
preference
and i'm going to summarize some of the
comments here the reddit user who wrote
this out is kiwi hellenist who's an
expert in early greek literature so
let's go through the video
and we are now going to really focus in
on the substance it is an unintelligible
word salad and it's also wrong on the
substance so let's just jump right in
so i just walked through the museum of
the bible in washington that was very
cool it's a very cool museum so the
structure that's with the best yeah
that's what i figured out i mean i just
figured this out this week
so it was a cool
it was a cool thing to walk through
because
it's it's chronological they have one
floor which is the history of the bible
it's not exactly that it's really what
it is is the history of the book right
now in many ways the first book was the
bible okay
in many ways the first book was the
bible now what does he mean by that uh
he says he's talking about the history
of the book not the content okay so if
that's what he means the first book was
not the bible books date back to the
start of the second millennium bc the
bible dates to no earlier than the
seventh century bc or bce as is now
often said some of it came much later
than that even and the new testament is
even newer so okay first statement
the first book was not the bible it's
just it's a factually incorrect
statement
i mean literally
because
at one point there was only one book
okay
i mean literally it was the first book
because at one point there was only one
book
at one point
i guess there was only one book but it
wasn't the bible
it it was the bible was not that book
like as far as our western culture is
concerned there's one book no that's
that's not true
the hebrew bible is made up of a bunch
of different texts and they were written
over a period of time that is about 500
years
and prior to that there were many books
that were written uh it's what what he's
saying is it's it's factually untrue
there's no i mean i'm like over
explaining it it's just not true and for
a while literally there was only one
book and that book was the bible and
then before it was the bible it was a
you know scrolls and it was writings on
papyrus and but it was we were starting
to aggregate written texts together and
it went through all sorts of
technological transformations and then
it became
books that everybody could buy the book
everybody could buy and the first one of
those was the bible and then it became
all sorts of books that everybody could
buy
but all those books in some sense
emerged out of that underlying book and
that book itself the bible isn't a book
it's a library
now
there's actually almost nothing to fact
check there
um
you know the writings on papyrus
those were the books of the time so to
say that because it was on papyrus
they're not really books it ignores the
reality of the times
not all future books emerged from the
bible either like the odyssey was
written in the 8th century bce
that didn't emerge from the bible most
of the iliad is older than the bible
that's a book whether it was written on
papyrus or not um and then there there's
this sort of last thing he says here oh
if the bible isn't a book it's a library
the bible isn't a book it's a library
it's a collection of books okay
it's not really clear what he means by
that the bible is a book made up of
different passages written at different
times and assembled together it's a
pretty vague statement and as the
culmination of everything else that he
said that's straight up wrong it's not
really worth much one way or the other
to say the bible is a library it's not
just that if it sounds like a word salad
we're not smart enough to understand it
to all the people emailing me insisting
me how right he is he is wrong he is
wrong it doesn't make any sense it
doesn't mean everything he says is wrong
but he's completely wrong about just
about everything he said in that clip
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter deepakman
as someone who watches youtube you know
how annoying it is to watch ads at the
beginning of videos that are completely
irrelevant to the content you're
watching that's why you always click the
skip ad button our sponsor thought
leaders has just launched a new
targeting tool that allows advertisers
to choose the precise videos where their
ads will appear using the advanced
search in the thought leaders platform
which is powered by ai you can actually
find youtube videos relevant to your
brand's messaging and with thought
leaders precision targeting you can
really make every view count optimize
your ad spend improve your conversions
when brands put their ads on relevant
videos they catch their audience when
they are most receptive and create a
more fulfilling enjoyable youtube
experience for everyone involved plans
start at just sixty dollars a month but
you can try it now for just thirty
dollars for the first month when you
click the link below and use the code
pacman at checkout